[Music]
in Arizona Sunday when the Eagles face
the Chiefs in Super Bowl 57 they'll
leave nothing on the field in an epic
battle that will surely require some
major recovery time after the game
but turns out that is also true for many
of the estimated 100 million Americans
expected to watch the big game on TV you
better believe this team's the one that
can do it and
instead of sore muscles and bruises they
may have other complaints over
indulgence in pizza and wings perhaps or
too much beer and booze or
just staying up too late but the result
according to the workforce institute's
annual Super Bowl poll roughly one out
of five employed Americans an estimated
26 million people are likely to miss at
least some work on Monday about 19
million of those workers the ones who
don't work from home plan to skip work
outright or take the day off nearly 8
million plan to sleep in and show up
late and for the diehards who do manage
to make their way into the workplace on
time 33 percent say they will likely be
less productive because of the Super
Bowl festivities the night before
according to the folks at Workforce it's
an economically costly problem that's
not likely to improve anytime soon
unless of course you happen to live in
Tennessee earlier this week State Rep
Joe towns Jr co-sponsored a bill that
would name the Monday after the Super
Bowl and if official state holiday where
did this idea for Super Bowl Monday come
from so it's just kind of like in
general conversation when you're hanging
out with the guys and the gals having a
good time on those days man I wish I
didn't have to go to work you know it's
kind of like that in fact that Workforce
poll found around 42 percent of U.S
employees agree believing the day after
the Super Bowl should be a holiday so
where is this bill now well the bill has
just been drafted we had our debt lines
last week so it's just been drafted and
I'm working an amendment now so this
won't help people for this year's Super
Bowl this would be for the Super Bowl
next year absolutely hey you could have
the Titans in the Super Bowl then next
year now you just spoke it and okay I
decree it okay the Titans will be in the
Super Bowl you heard it here first but
as for this year's game so I have about
three places I'll stop by and uh the
last one would be the one that'll cause
me to want to have a day off that was
exactly where I was going are you going
to be showing up to work on time on
Monday well I think that with me being
initiated this kind of building
everybody ever know that I would be
pulling the leg if I called in sick okay
so I have to be here I will be right at
work
I actually feel like he shouldn't be at
work to make the point that you need to
have the bill I mean look this is we
were even talking about I said to him
what about let's do this during the NCAA
tournament there's also all the studies
that show all the lack of productivity
during the first week of the NCAA
tournament on Thursday and Friday a lot
of people are behind this in Cincinnati
last year the schools I think delayed
the start times so the kids could watch
so look people would like to watch their
game and enjoy it and you've got to
recover I saw I heard one stat this week
that some people you know when they make
a lot of food eat up to 11
000 calories
on Super Bowl Sunday that means a lot of
sleep time after treatment yeah I guess
or go to the gym maybe I guess so there
you go I shouldn't go on the diet later
on so maybe not maybe not today or
tomorrow Tuesday after the Super Bowl
okay